[Musica]
io parto per una domanda il cibo può
comunicare con il nostro dna e se
comunica con il nostro dna può
influenzare la salute pensiamo una prima
immagine alle api
abbiamo tre tipi di api la pop e ryan di
fuoco e l'ape regina
tutte e tre hanno il medesimo dna
medesimo genoma ma l'ape regina è stata
nutrita dalla larva con un cibo un cibo
diverso
la pappa reale e come vediamo le
dimensioni dell'ape regina sono
differenti ma non solo le dimensioni la
sua funzione differente è l'unica
all'interno dell'arnia che si può
riprodurre il può dare origine a una
nuova colonia allora il cibo ha
comunicato qualcosa al dna perché tutte
hanno lo stesso dna e per capire questo
abbiamo dentro c nel molto piccolo
nel nucleo delle nostre cellule 2 micron
che racchiudono 3 miliardi di basi che
il nostro genoma lungo circa due metri
molto impacchettato pensate che alla
fine degli anni 90 si pensava quello
studio del genoma umano che se avrebbe
avuto grandi risposte seal di
comprensione delle malattie ma anche di
comprensione sul dna
in realtà si è capito che eravamo solo
all'inizio perché solo il 23 per cento
del dna codifica per una proteina è
pertanto una funzione
tutto il resto e pensate 98 per cento un
dna che all'epoca era considerato janke
viene scusate il termine inglese
spazzatura che serviva come backup per
far sì che le mutazioni cadessero non
sui geni
in realtà questo dna e si è scoperto che
avevamo l'inizio di una nuova avventura
che si genera era funzionale a regolare
l'espressione dei geni
e come ci sono dei marcatori chimici sul
dna delle bandierine che durante lo
sviluppo vengono opposte sul dna e
queste bandierine che possono essere o
dirette sul dna o sulle proteine che
avvolgono il dna o addirittura su alcuni
reati sono lo stampo del dna antisenso
vengono poste durante lo sviluppo finché
le cellule possono compiere la loro
funzione
pensate che noi abbiamo nel nostro le
nostre cellule in ogni cellula lo stesso
medesimo dna ma ogni cellula svolge una
funzione differente perché perché scrive
parti del dna differente grazie a queste
bandierine a questi marcatori che dice a
un gene tu devi essere espresso in
questa cellula di far sì che pesa
cellule abbia questa funzione è un'altra
cellula un'altra per capire meglio
immaginiamo che il nostro dna sia uno
spartito orchestrale e i geni siano gli
strumenti se sono essere tutti insieme
non ci sarebbe un armonia non ci sarebbe
una sinfonia non sarebbe la musica ci
sarebbe solo rumore in realtà ogni gene
sa perfettamente
grazie a queste bandierina questi marker
quando entrare in funzione quando
suonare quando stare zitto se suonare
forte se suonare piano ecco questa
armonia si svolge in ogni secondo ogni
istante all'interno delle nostre cellule
e c'è uno studio uno studio estremamente
interessante fatto sui topi si nella
biologia si parte sempre da un modello
sperimentale spesso sono i topi a due
mamme quella stessa genetica sottotuta
mangiare del cibo a una mamma del cibo
povero povero di nutrienti un'altra
mamma è stato dato da mangiare un cibo
ricco di altrimenti soprattutto
particolari nutrienti vitamine
il risultato è stato che i cuccioli di
queste due mamme hanno avuto un fenotipo
cioè una manifestazione di quello che
sono differenti addirittura il colore
del manto è cambiato perché il cibo ha
comunicato una cosa differente
durante lo sviluppo di questi bambini
questi cuccioli
ha i geni e allora pensiamo al cibo ai
nostri giorni
andiamo su questo piccolo pianeta come
dice edgar morin persone che muoiono di
fame persone che mangiano in eccesso
abbiamo spreco di cibo abbiamo persone
che si ammalano perché mangiano troppo
mangiano male e abbiamo anche una
situazione paradossale chiamata deserto
nutrizionale
io sco di casa in dieci minuti non
riesco a recuperare cibo ricco di vita
nel recuperare solo cibo cosiddetto non
mi piace il termine perché sul cibo e
sempre bisogna sempre avere rispetto
cibo che ha solo calorie ma non a
nutriente essenziale è la cosa più
interessante che l'ambiente il cibo
vostri di vite anche le emozioni possono
scrivere sul dna e possono parlare quel
dna e questo scrivere può essere
trasmesso soprattutto se questo avviene
durante i primi 1000 giorni di vita del
bambino dal concepimento al terzo anno
di età
questa scrittura può passare anche da
una generazione un'altra e cioè
un'evidenza un'evidenza storica di
questo passaggio intergenerazionale di
quanto l'ambiente e il cibo abbia
influenzato la salute delle generazioni
successive
questo uno studio storico avvenuto in
olanda se studiata una popolazione di 45
milioni di persone olandesi che durante
la seconda guerra mondiale fu confinata
in una zona molto ristretta dell'olanda
inverno da una parte c'erano le truppe
tedesche dall'altra parte i canali
ghiacciati questa popolazione visse per
nove mesi circa mangiando pochissimo di
stenti arrivarono addirittura a mangiare
pensate i bulbi dei tulipani e si
calcolò che mangiarono circa 500 kcal al
giorno si sono studiate i bambini nati
dalle mamme che durante quel periodo
erano in gravidanza gli spettavano di
questi bambini hanno mantenuto la
programmazione delle loro mamme le loro
mamme avevano vissuto senza cibo e
quando sono nati questi quindi erano
programmati a resistere all assenza di
cibo guerra poi finita hanno avuto
accesso a cibo e questi bimbi sono stati
più esposti a una vulnerabilità
sanitaria più esposti a diabete obesità
sovrappeso malattia cardiovascolare e
anche tumore e questa vulnerabilità
questo momento di rischio se anche è
ripresentato nella seconda e adesso si
sta studiando la terza generazione
ora dobbiamo pensare dal piccolo perché
il piccolo ci possa suggerire delle
azioni da fare nel grande per migliorare
la società e per migliorare anche
l'aspettativa di salute della nostra
società ripensare all'origine delle
malattie e del modo migliore di
promuovere la salute portare la scienza
del piccolo questi meccanismi
meravigliosi che avvengono nelle nostre
cellule
nelle scelte grandi investire
soprattutto sulle classi che hanno meno
consapevolezza di tutto questo che hanno
accesso a cibo povero perché costa poco
perché hanno magari un basso reddito
perché magari hanno anche una bassa
scolarizzazione che non gli può far
accedere a questi tipi di messaggi
soprattutto investire nelle mamme perché
il diritto alla salute anche sancito
dalla costituzione sia un diritto anche
di giustizia intergenerazionale dobbiamo
pensare la nostra salute
bene prezioso a pesare anche poterla
mettere alle generazioni successive e
loro dobbiamo un po risvegliarci è
questo il mio risveglio
c'è un origine che pone una
vulnerabilità maggiore alle malattie
importante sono i primi 1000 giorni di
vita del bambino
c'è forse questa è una domanda che mi
faccio sempre un'evoluzione silenziosa
che porta una società ad avere una
prospettiva di salute diversa rispetto a
un'altra
perché c'è un accesso al cibo differente
e questa evoluzione continuerà per
fortuna può essere reversibile
se le condizioni cambiano e se il cibo
che ovviamente mangia la mamma mangiamo
noi cambia allora se è vero che è
importante per la salute dei nascituri
anche delle generazioni successive
l'ambiente e il cibo che mangia la mamma
allora dobbiamo curare il cibo è tutta
tutto ciò che è l'ambiente attorno alle
mamme tono quelle che sono le nuove vite
allora dobbiamo pensare ogni momento in
cui la persona mangia e curare questo
momento può essere l'ospedale non
possiamo tralasciare e lasciare che il
cibo diventa solo un servizio
alberghiero cibo deve trasmettere dei
valori deve essere importante
trasmettere anche salute alle scuole
dove tanti genitori sono più preoccupati
se i bambini non mangiano ma mai si
preoccupano se bambino mangia male
sempre la preoccupazione il mio figlio
non mangia ma preoccupiamoci cosa mangia
preoccupiamoci se quello che mangia
importante per la sua salute
e poi ci sono le aziende in ogni momento
ma anche tra amici un marketing della
salute che può essere anche trasversale
con la società pensiamo in ogni momento
in cui si mangia quanto possiamo
comunicare attraverso un cibo deve
essere sempre buono ma anche funzionale
alla salute perché il cibo è
un'interconnessione dal nostro passato
al nostro presente ma anche al nostro
futuro ci interconnette con la terra
perché il cibo e lavoro viene prodotto
viene trasformato
rispetto con gli esseri viventi con
l'ambiente diceva una grande agronoma
inglese che la salute dell'uomo degli
animali della terra dell'acqua e
dell'aria è unica e indivisibile e poi
pensiamo noi ci nutriamo di molecole che
sono i carboidrati dove il carbonio e
nello stato chimico di legame ad alta
energia e questo legame ad alta energia
lorica val che cosa dalle piante perché
le piante invece trasformano grazie
all'energia solare una molecola di
carbonio che ha un legame a bassa
energia la co2 cosa ossigeno ad alta
energia per la proprietà transitiva ora
possiamo dire che mangiavo grazie
all'energia del sole
dobbiamo rispettare questo tipo di
ambiente intorno a noi ci ricollega
interconnessione con noi stessi con la
nostra storia
pensiamo ai profumi profumi che evocano
delle emozioni profumi della cucina
della nonna
siamo proust e madeleine che siamo a
quanto il cibo lega la tradizione la
storia e da parte del nostro passato ma
è parte anche del nostro futuro e da
parte anche di quello che possiamo
trasmettere alle generazioni successive
a volte invece si mangiano anche cibi
standard con dei profumi standard dei
sapori standard e questo penso sia un
avvilimento anche di quello che è un
nostro organo di senso perché abbiamo
cinque organi di senso e largo nel senso
del gusto un organo meraviglioso abbiamo
attraverso il gusto cinque gusti ma
attraverso l'organo bomber una sale che
lui fatto milioni di possibilità di
apprezzare i sapori profumi volte il
cibo industriale molto processato
non ce vo che sempre lo stesso sempre
uguale e dobbiamo investire nella
cultura del cibo che una cultura che
diversa dalla prevenzione però possono
ad avere davvero dei link in comune e
poi nutrire è il primo atto che svolge
la mamma nutrirà maron cibo che nutre è
un cibo che ama e poi ovviamente le
nostre tradizioni elezioni che fanno sì
che ci sia un quotidiano più frugale ma
sempre buono è una festa che dobbiamo
aspettare attendere per poter
condividere un cibo più ricco
con i nostri cari e allora l'epigenetica
che cos'è dai pi greco sopra il dna
tutte queste modifiche sopra il dna è un
ponte che lega l'ambiente ahimè anche
l'inquinamento l'emozione il cibo il
cibo che è un po tutto questo al nostro
dna
pensavamo che il dna fosse un codice
immutabile alto basso occhi azzurri
occhi neri
in realtà abbiamo capito attraverso
questi ultimi studi che sono sono poi
così recenti per forma e 15 anni che si
studia in questo senso che possiamo
avere un dialogo quel dna e possiamo
anche trasmettere la nostra storia alle
generazioni successive per io penso una
prospettiva di salute più equa e uguale
per tutti e per permettere alle nuove
generazioni ad avere anche meno
vulnerabilità a determinate malattie
grazie
[Applauso]